a valuable lesson you can learn from Top
creators is that they have a goal a
message they want to get out a Target
like you look at Mr Beast he literally
just wants to be the biggest YouTuber in
the world it's like a driving passion
for him maybe it's to raise a certain
amount of money that'll keep you
motivated through the hard times on
YouTube
one of my passions over the years is
studying the principles and lessons that
I can learn from Top performers in any
industry and in my case that is learning
from Top YouTube creators and even more
so business owners and entrepreneurs
that are using video to reach more
people and generate more income and I've
really discovered after interviewing now
hundreds of different people that have
started YouTube channels and have had
extraordinary success over an extended
time Horizon four valuable lessons that
you and I can apply whether we're just
starting or we want to scale our channel
to the next level and the first one is
that top YouTube and successful YouTube
creators start before they're ready now
maybe you've heard this before but it
needs to be said when you study the
greats you gotta understand that they
started mess see friend listen there's
never going to be the perfect time see
if you're waiting for the perfect time
it will never come
you're never gonna have the perfect
calendar you know what when things are
just a little bit lighter on my calendar
maybe when the kids are back in school
and when I'm in this different season
now of course you have to be practical
about the season that you're in but what
I've learned is that there's just never
the perfect calendar for starting
anything let alone a YouTube channel
what there is is just the commitment to
starting and making it a priority some
people delay you're never gonna have the
perfect body you know what I'm gonna
start YouTube when I lose 10 pounds you
know I don't want to get on camera yet
until I I hit the tanning salon I don't
want to get on camera yet until I get
that teeth that work done on my teeth
listen you're never gonna be in the
perfect circumstances maybe waiting
until you have the perfect marriage
you're never going to have the perfect
marriage right the perfect marriage
doesn't exist I'm just gonna wait until
my spouse isn't going so crazy and uh
isn't isn't causing me all this stress
because I can't focus and I can't film
listen stop May making excuses and start
before you're ready what you really have
to do is you have to overcome the
circumstances that you're in when I've
talked to so many different creators
I've learned that they might have
started their YouTube channel in a
recession they started their YouTube
channel because they got fired at their
job they started their YouTube channel
because they just wanted that creative
outlet and they hated their job so much
that they stopped filling their extra
hours with consuming Netflix and
consuming Hulu and instead they started
creating content and they stopped
waiting for the perfect time to start
why because it doesn't exist all you
really have is today and I would venture
to say that if you're listening to this
very think media podcast you're clearly
already considering starting or
continuing to stay committed to your
YouTube channel so friend you gotta go
all in right people wait but wait when I
get the perfect camera this is the
biggest one when I get the perfect
camera that's what I'm gonna start no
you gotta just start with the smartphone
that you already have one my idea isn't
quite perfect I I've got should I start
my Channel about this should I start my
Channel about this or should I start my
Channel about this I don't know grab
your smartphone pick one and press
record you literally have to start
before you're ready and this is a trend
across the board that I see from Top
creators and I love this quote from
George Patton and it says this a good
plan violently executed Now is better
than the perfect plan executed next week
listen good enough to start is all you
need that means messy that means poop
your pants scared that means you got
sweat in your armpits it means you might
be a little bit nervous but friend
you're gonna be in good company when you
start before you're ready if you've ever
seen my first video I made a claim on
that video where I said listen I'm not
going to be entered energetic or
entertaining I guess this is the first
Sean thinks Vlog I'm gonna try to Vlog
every day I didn't do that I'm gonna I'm
not gonna be energetic or entertaining
hopefully I got a little bit more
energetic and more entertaining but all
I did was I started messy and friend you
need to do the same and I want to talk
about Jim rohn's law of diminishing
intent so Jim Rohn kind of famous
leadership coach came up with this
and here's the quote and this is why
it's so important to start and this is
why all the greats all the those that
are succeeding your competitors right
now the people that you're looking up to
right now
they understood that you have to start
before circumstances are perfect and
here's the quote the longer you wait to
do something you should do now the
greater the odds that you will never
actually do it what's the difference
between those succeeding on YouTube and
those that are staying stuck those that
are succeeding started messy they put
out 10 bad videos they put out 50 bad
videos they put out hundreds of bad
videos they just started moving remember
you cannot steer
a parked car
you gotta start before you're ready
and your growth Zone will always be at
the edge of your comfort zone but Sean I
don't feel ready yet I'm not really
comfortable yet exactly
you gotta start and then you start to
grow into it you gotta start and then
there's actually some momentum to steer
you gotta start when you feel
uncomfortable and you're second guessing
what people on the other side of the
camera are thinking and you're worried
what about what that person in high
school that's not even watching your
content is thinking oh who does she
think she is to start a Channel or who
does he think he is to promote his
business oh he's so self-absorbed to be
promoting his business on YouTube listen
you got to shut out the noise from the
voices that actually aren't even paying
attention to what you're doing but all
that self-talk that's holding you back
and you gotta start before you're ready
everyone I talk to they just punch fear
in the face and they started they didn't
know how to edit they didn't know what
software they were going to use
necessarily they just grabbed the camera
they had the smartphone that they had
they shot 100 videos and then they
pivoted their Channel but Sean what if I
don't want to shoot 100 videos and I
don't have the perfect idea yet because
I would have wasted my time that whole
time no you wouldn't have wasted your
time every
failure quote unquote was just actually
a lesson getting you closer to what your
success was it's the Thomas Edison quote
he before he got the light bulb that
worked he had 2 000 failed experiments
but those weren't failures they were
just proving what didn't work and it got
him to the light bulb that worked every
video you post is an experiment helping
you get closer to your your voice your
message your place of personal power on
YouTube I have some successful YouTube
channels now but what a lot of people
don't know is that I've got like four
Failed YouTube channels you can look up
think International clearvision media
you can look up my Sean Cannell Channel
these are all kind of like I'm not
uploading in these places they're random
there's different content that I posted
there there aren't even failures but
they're all abandoned they're not what
I'm doing today
but what were they you can look up the
Turning Point Church YouTube channel
from 2007 the church doesn't even exist
anymore those four YouTube channels
were my lessons they were these Stepping
Stones failures are Stepping Stones to
success those were the experiments that
helped me get where I am today we got to
get into the next three points but I
want to encourage you join top YouTube
creators by starting before you're ready
not being afraid to start small not
being afraid to start messy but just
starting secondly
a valuable lesson I've noticed is that
when these creators are starting they do
start with the end in mind and here's
what I mean by that Sean I thought you
just said start before you have the
perfect idea I agree you should start
before your idea is perfect because
there are even no perfect ideas you
gotta start and what you'll notice is
that your idea will evolve and change
along the way but it is good to start
with the end in mind so here's a couple
questions why do you want to start a
YouTube channel like what is the end
goal and that end goal could be oh I
want a million subscribers okay set
those goals
okay I want to earn a certain amount a
month and quit my job I encourage you to
write some of these things down
but also like what is it what impact do
you want to make
what is motivating you to start your
YouTube channel
you know for me I first started from my
local church because my motivation was
to Market my local church was to get the
word out about what I believe is a
life-changing message right the gospel
and from the local church I want people
to know like we're doing church so I
started to get into social media back in
2007 when we started the church we
actually I was in a small town hour
north of Seattle and so we started to do
Twitter it was super weird right we
started a vlog for the pastor we started
a YouTube channel and and so the mission
was motivating the reason to start
that's why that YouTube channel started
then I started a business because I
taught myself video and it's I didn't go
to film school and I I'm not the biggest
believer in college but I'm a huge
believer in education especially in
self-education and picking out your
curriculum so I've been a ravenous
learner and I was investing in programs
and courses and things to learn video
and and eventually I started Clear
Vision media doing wedding videos and
video production
and so the goal of that was to build a
portfolio and to build up my YouTube
channel so I could get more clients and
have a place where I showed off my work
and again you can look up this YouTube
channel it's called clearvision media
not that you're interested but it's like
you can see the old portfolio of my work
doing music videos for Seattle hip-hop
artists and doing wedding videos and
doing business uh local business videos
and so that was the the purpose number
two is start with the end in mind like
what's the goal of the YouTube channel
and then I hit the hardest season of My
Life
and this is 2009 when actually my wife
almost died
and because of a chronic illness and
eventually a botched surgery she found
herself in the hospital for six days and
I was by her side
on top of that The Big Short the housing
bubble crashed and we're in a major
recession and then on top of that the
church I was a part of who I was doing
the YouTube stuff for that fell apart
some senior leaders stole some money and
uh there was some toxic leadership stuff
and so our whole world was kind of
falling apart around us and I got a
whole nother level of purpose a whole
other level of vision in the midst of
wanting to give up and wanting to quit
and then realizing that I either give up
and give in or I either you know dig in
my heels
and commit to fighting for my family I
either man up and really actually build
something to pay these medical bills
because now I had started my Clear
Vision media business and I've done the
YouTube channel and I'd been
continuously reading and studying and
buying courses and buying books and
learning I started to understand I was
like okay this YouTube thing's real I
learned about what's called affiliate
marketing learn about different ways to
monetize so I just got a whole other
vision of starting with the end in mind
and I started a channel called think
media and here we are today you know 12
years later since think media started on
the think media podcast which is another
our second Channel now to think media
where we host our podcasts and our live
shows and
I've learned this that reasons come
first and results come second that when
I've studied top YouTubers and if you
really squeeze them you'll find a reason
that motivates them you know the root
word of motivation is motive what's your
motive for starting a YouTube channel if
you want to stay motivated get stronger
reasons reasons come first so my reasons
at this point in my life were then okay
I gotta pay these medical bills I got to
provide for my wife
I gotta find a way out of this situation
I want to find a way to work from home I
want to figure this thing out and so
ultimately what are your reasons and
what's the end goal you want your
YouTube channel to have in mind don't
let this be conflicted with start before
you're ready
it's not having everything perfectly
planned it's not knowing exactly what
it's going to look like I can tell you
this friend 12 years after starting
think media it looks radically different
than I thought it would look I have no
idea that I was going to be living in
Vegas I had no idea who would be working
here or even fully what we would be
doing but I had a general goal it was
provide for my family it was make a
difference it was just teach what I know
up until that point I started teaching
video reviewing cameras teaching about
lenses teaching about how to save money
on cameras and how to shoot video
because I've been doing video production
since 2003. I taught what I know I was
helping me yesterday you need help with
video I've been doing it for a while I'm
gonna do my best to help you and that's
what I started then who do you want to
help who do you want to serve what's the
difference you want to make what's the
reason you want to start your YouTube
channel a valuable lesson you can learn
from Top creators is that they have a
goal a message they want to get out a
Target
like you look at Mr Beast he literally
just wants to be the biggest YouTuber in
the world it's like a driving passion
for him maybe it's to raise a certain
amount of money that'll keep you
motivated through the hard times on
YouTube
start with the end in mind
are you ready to start or grow your
YouTube channel do you feel stuck and
need help connecting the dots join this
free web class where you'll learn the
step-by-step playbook for YouTube
success we've helped thousands of
purpose-driven entrepreneurs just like
you grow their influence with video
register today for this exclusive
training at thinkmasterclass.com
number three
they commit to the process they commit
to the process
as I study top creators
I realize that not only did they start
in imperfect circumstances that again
maybe they were facing chronic health
issues maybe they were you know in a
season where there was a lot of drama
and turmoil in their life but they just
started but I'll tell you this after
they started
trouble came then too here's a promise
for you this will be hard
here's another promise you will want to
quit
and the unexpected is gonna happen for
sure
you know over the last 12 years I just
think about we went from Seattle we were
in Marysville Washington and while I was
building my YouTube channel
especially in those very early days the
money wasn't coming in
enough at first the first check I got
from Amazon Affiliates was two dollars
and 12 cents I could not provide for my
family with that
and so through God's provision I was
introduced to the opportunity to take a
position to work at a church in 2011 and
that's why we originally moved to Las
Vegas so that was unexpected though my
wife never thought we'd be living in
Vegas I never thought we would and even
in that season while I was doing YouTube
on the side and in in Church media and
being the director of communications I
got to learn more I got to learn about
writing and Publishing books as I helped
my pastor launch Books
I got to learn about Facebook ads and
marketing as we had a TV show and we had
different you know we'd advertise Easter
and we'd get the word out about what's
happening I got to work with a bigger
staff I got to learn about bigger
leadership challenges and all kinds of
different things it was unexpected and
and then through the highs and the lows
we continue to face you know medical
challenges uh in the journey with my
wife's Health we continue to face uh
different marital challenges because you
know anybody who's married knows a
marriage can be hard and and we continue
to face ups and downs in all kinds of
areas and we saw slow growth on YouTube
and Seasons where I wanted to quit
because man why am I working so hard on
my side hustle with the energy I have
left over of what all the rest of life
is taking from me friend there's
something about being committed to the
process and as I have talked to others
I've learned that their situations have
not been perfect no ones have right that
they've faced challenges with family
members with friends with for a while
they were getting tons of views and all
of a sudden their views got cut in half
for a while they their videos were
working and all of a sudden what they
thought was working is not working is
good anymore
I love this quote from Tony Robbins that
says stay committed to your decisions
but stay flexible in your approach top
YouTube creators today I mean here's a
secret right the reason they're still on
top is because they've continued to stay
flexible
and the reason they're still on top this
one will blow your mind
is because they continue
to post YouTube videos I mean it might
be a surprise right but I mean like if
you stop posting YouTube videos you're
probably no longer on top as a YouTube
Creator because you're no longer posting
videos and that might seem kind of basic
but but friend even if you haven't
posted a video yet it's kind of a mental
shift to think about I mean this is
actually kind of a Content creation
lifestyle this is a Content creation
habit this is a Content creation
commitment and on the other side of that
commitment though is reaching those
goals of growth impact money on the
other side of that commitment is
reaching those goals if you have the
ambition and you're listening to this
that I want to start a channel and I
want to succeed on YouTube there's
something about being committed to the
process and what commitment looks like
is I'm committed when it's good and I
feel like doing it doing it and it look
it's being committed when I don't feel
like doing it anybody can get up and
shoot a video like man I just woke up
today and it just feels amazing and you
know you're singing in the shower
breakfast just hit different different
that was some really good coffee you
just feel pumped you feel like you got
the clarity you're excited about your
video idea everything seems to go be
going right you're so thankful you
actually charged your batteries on your
camera you know everything's just
flowing your spa your spouse just leapt
out of bed and was like honey you look
amazing today you're gonna crush it on
camera things are just you're so smart
and intelligent and you know you get a
text message from a friend that's just
like I just want to tell you you're the
greatest hey I don't know what you're up
to today but like I just appreciate you
so much get a smoothie just delicious
little whey protein blend up some
strawberries on your break from shooting
videos your energy is Tip Top your
mental Clarity couldn't be clearer just
an amazing day that happens never like
I've never I don't know if I've ever had
a shoot day that has felt like that you
know what I mean typically if I'm about
to record some YouTube videos I wake up
and then I'm like Oh my back freaking
hurts like I just don't know what it is
my lower back what is going on with my
lower back you know I kind of go down to
the coffee maker I open up my coffee
beans to put them into my Burr grinder
and I spill them on the floor like you
know what I mean like I'm pouring into
the thing I'm like freaking crap is this
how my day's gonna go and then I'm like
okay maybe my wife will encourage me and
sure enough she like wakes up she's like
hey honey
I'm like great it's not bad but she
didn't wake up and was like you know
what you're gonna freaking Crush today
you're just you know what I mean like
it's you're going through life and then
you get a text message and it's like
your bank account's overdrawn you know
what I mean and then like like it's just
typically everything when you're trying
to create content and trying to grow
your business and like trying like
you're facing challenge after challenge
after challenge you look into your
YouTube analytics and you just you had a
video schedule uploaded you thought this
one was great the thumbnail was amazing
the title was amazing you look at it you
look at it and it's it's 10 out of 10.
and anyone who knows YouTube analytics
you're looking for that one out of ten
you're like holy crap that was the worst
uh out of my last 10 videos
um and I gave that one the best effort
I've ever given in fact it took me 20
hour hours to edit that like and now my
heart is defeated and my soul is cold
you know what I mean like you're like
just this is reality and friend you
gotta commit to the process
top creators man through recessions
through the highs and the lows there's
going to be highs and lows in your
energy could be highs and lows in your
health and listen I'm not talking about
any kind of weird hustle culture you of
course gotta rest you got to pace
yourself but the commitment is the slow
and steady March so I'm going to keep
posting I'm going to keep learning I'm
going to keep leveling up my skills I'm
going to stay committed to the decision
to start and grow a YouTube channel I'm
going to stay committed to the decision
knowing that this stuff works because
the proof is there that it works the
proof is there that the customers the
community members the patrons the
affiliate marketing the course sales
whatever your business model the YouTube
ad Revenue it works you make a decision
to say I am going to do this thing but
you gotta stay flexible in your approach
realize it's going to be a process and
make a commitment to not give up
number four
and finally valuable lessons I've
learned from Top creators is they're
consistent over time
they're consistent
over time
what is interesting is I've also had the
chance not everyone I've interviewed out
of the hundreds of creators are still
around today
many people have had 15 minutes of
YouTube Fame
they've come and they've gone I was
talking to I believe my friend Matt
Koval at VidCon
he's been there for like the last 12
years that VidCon has happened and he
said what's so weird is it's an entirely
new generation of characters
all the people who are originally there
aren't even around anymore they're doing
other things now there's scenarios where
maybe that's not a bad thing people can
retire they can change careers they
could decide I don't want to do this
anymore but unfortunately there's a lot
of people who probably did want to do it
but they didn't really know how to
reinvent themselves when the thing that
they started with isn't working anymore
there's a lot of people who
still would want to be experiencing the
accolades and the YouTube success and
the income and all everything else that
comes with it
but they had some things happen in their
life that kind of knocked them out of
the game
that's not coming from a judgmental
standpoint it's coming from an
observational standpoint that there's
something about staying consistent
keyword over time
you know great things take time and
patience and there's many people I've
talked to that I've realized that that
overnight success is never overnight I
remember talking to Barnacles nerdgasm
kind of has like a tech type of Channel
he said it took like seven years to get
to like 70 000 subscribers seven years
but then he got to 700 000 I believe in
the next year A lot of times you'll see
that there are creators that 12 24 36
months not a lot to show for things the
classic story of Mr Beast posted 200
videos before anything starts to happen
the classic story of you go into MKBHD
his Tech Channel right now looking at
his oldest video where he's just
shooting on a janky webcam horrible
video quality talking about a laptop
there's something about going back to
the first think media video or the first
video and just seeing that it's not just
about starting before you're ready and
it's not just about starting with the
end in mind and it's not just about
being committed to the process for like
one day or one week or even one year
there's something about committing to
the process and being consistent over
time and I've learned that most people
overestimate what they can accomplish in
one year
but they underestimate what they can
accomplish in 10 years see we get so
pumped and I'm here listen subscribe to
the think media podcast we're here to
help you win subscribe to think media on
YouTube subscribe to the audio podcast
because we have audio only episodes that
you'll want to get as well
and we're here to help you win quick
help you go viral help you at grow as
fast as possible and we have so many of
our community members who are doing that
we have many of our video ranking
Academy students which is our YouTube
course who have grown and built like
crazy incomes in as short as six months
but that is also the exception of the
rule and I'm not trying to you know
share like hype over here like I'd
really like to stay grounded to say like
this world is so real but this world it
really does take real work and I what's
more common
is the 12-month Journey the 24 month
Journey what's even more common is
understanding that YouTube starting a
YouTube channel is essentially starting
a small business and when you study
small business you recognize that it
takes 12 to 24 to 36 months this is what
the data shows us for a small business
to even become profitable think about it
you launch a small business you might go
to a local bank and say I want to open a
coffee shop you get a loan they give you
100 Grand you have to lease the property
get some signage buy your a special
machine hire a barista hire someone to
work the till buy some furniture get the
place decorated you're paying all this
money out then you need to just pay for
the electricity pay for the water pay
for the almond milk pay for the oat milk
pay for the real milk pay for how many
different milks can we have right and
get all the different assets together
investing in your business that's why it
takes so long to be profitable because
you're hustling you're putting time in
you're putting money in and it takes a
year or two or three to even start now
coming out ahead profit-wise my friend
that's the mindset that I want you to
have here's what's crazy about the
crater economy is I really do hope you
get excited about the fact that if you
really hustle and you really stay
committed to this process here's the
thing too some people like join our
course or listen to this podcast this
kind of Dabble but if you like grab a
journal like binge our podcast like join
our course and actually watch all the
modules and Implement everything you're
learning and take detailed notes and
calendar block this thing out this is up
to you your pace you can crush this
thing we're living in a world where
there can be rapid success and I want
that for you and I think the tension
that's best to live in is striving for
as quick growth as possible but having
the calm and collected emotion emotional
fortitude of saying yeah but I'm just
committed to this process over the Long
Haul I hope and even believe that in the
next six to 12 months I could replace my
income and work from home full-time
doing this because that's real but I
also understand that if it takes 24
months or 36 or if it takes five years
or seven years like Barnacles nerdgasm
that I am committed to being consistent
over time
because the typical story of those who
make it are those that persevere and do
not quit when times get tough and
continue to learn and adapt and maybe
they're not as they don't have the
blueprint like we're giving you at think
media like I did not have the blueprint
so I started a channel didn't work
started another Channel didn't work
started another one didn't work started
another one didn't work they all were
lessons in their own way
but of my four Failed YouTube channels I
learned so much that then I started
think media and actually had quite a bit
of clarity as messy as even that was I
had I had a pretty clear end in mind of
what it was going to be I was like okay
I know video tech is a thing people want
Tech videos they want to learn about
video and lenses and things like that I
can monetize through affiliate marketing
I got a business plan there it is I can
write it on a napkin make Tech videos
teach and do tutorials about best lenses
and best camera for YouTube connect to
affiliate marketing get enough views to
pay my bills I just wrote my whole
business plan on a napkin and as simple
as that sounds it was very difficult for
me to get that much Clarity and it took
hundreds of uploads and multiple
different channels and studying to get
there you can find your sweet spot and
breakthrough could be weeks away from
you for you when it comes to the
financial and subscriber goals that
you're after but more likely I'm just
trying to drill this in
there's more likely that it's going to
be about consistency over time and
here's my desire for you I hope you come
to our next live event in Las Vegas or
some city in the United States or
internationally I hope you come to a
Vegas influencers event and I hope you
come to the next one but I hope you come
in three years I hope to meet up with
you in six years I hope to shake your
hand in eight years and to hear your
story about you saying man it took a
while to get it dialed in I really just
did it on the side for a while but once
I really found my thing man I hit it and
it really now I got five people working
for me and we have a real Cool vibe we
have a team Dynamic and our YouTube
channel is popping off and we we're
we're monetizing we're on the blockchain
and we're creating all kinds of creative
stuff that we're doing we're living just
in the most amazing times in the world
to be an entrepreneur to create
something to monetize your message to
monetize and make a difference and have
a powerful Mission and a purpose that's
changing the world these tools before us
with the blockchain with YouTube with
social media and with video and with
live streaming and with all these
different things in e-commerce and all
this stuff we're living in that world
it's a commitment start before you're
ready
start with the end in mind and start
moving towards your goals and your
dreams as unclear as they may be
just get kinda clear and start moving
and then commit to the process and then
know that it's going to take consistent
commitment over
time